tout plaisir attendait les finales du
tournoi itf et futurs pas de chance
cette année il fallait surtout essayer
de ne pas s'endormir dans les tribunes
lors de la finale de ces dames au
concours du plus grand nombre de fautes
directes c'est la française iryna
brémond en noir et tête de série numéro
1 du tournoi qui sont des sorties le
mieux peut-être lassé de mettre ces coup
droit dans le filet mais surtout blessé
au tendon d'achille elitsa kostova
abandonne 3 partout dans le second set
après avoir perdu le premier 6 jeux à 3
côté hommes la logique a été respectée
face au talentueux suisse de 21 ans
sandro et rate le français marc gicquel
habitué des tournois du grand chelem
fait jouer son expérience pour faire
craquer le joueur helvète dans les
points importants victoire nette et sans
bavure 6-3 6-2 j'ai fait un match solide
j'ai bien joué les moments importants je
les jeux les bien retourner aussi quand
il fallait gt gt solide du début à la
fin j'ai bien fait servi pour finir et
je me sentais vraiment bien dans tous
les compartiments du jeu physiquement
j'étais bien et donc une semaine très
très satisfaisante à côté des
professionnels les jeunes pousses sont
eux aussi le droit à leur trophée à
l'issue des tournois jeunes organisait à
plaisir de quoi leur donner des envies
de gagner d'autres titres